même maupin ans correspondant rt aux
etats unis c'est notre rubrique vu de
l'extérieur ce soir bonsoir khaled ma
part merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france une vaccination donc médiatisé
celle de joe biden c'était nécessaire
pour rassurer la population américaine
face au vaccin ce président élu
photographié filmé par les caméras télé
en train de se faire vacciner personnes
aux états unis sont sceptiques
concernant le vaccin sont inquiet qui
pourrait y avoir un danger pour leur
santé
beaucoup de personnes sont inquiètes
parce que le développement a été trop
rapide tonk le fait que joe biden se
fassent vacciner devant les caméras
effectivement c'est considéré comme une
façon de rassurer la population alors
joe biden a remercié les scientifiques
qui ont rendu la vaccination possible
mais aussi l'administration trump pour
sar je suis contributions plutôt un
maigre hommage on aime ou on n'aime pas
donald trump mais il avait tout de même
annoncé le président sortant que la
vaccination aurait lieu avant novembre
il avait annoncé quelques semaines
quelques mois avant provoquant alors
lire et les critiques des démocrates
je pense que joe biden en ce moment
essaye de souligner qu'il veut réunifier
le pays qu'il veut guérir les plaies
soufferte sous le mandat de donald trump
je ne pense pas qu'il réussira à faire
cela rapidement
mais on pourrait l'interpréter comme une
tendu une main la main de l'amitié verte
et personne au sein du camp trump e pour
les personnes de l'administration trump
en tout cas la lutte contre le virus est
une priorité absolue pour joe biden il
l'a dit pendant la campagne il l'a redit
après est-ce que les américains doivent
s'attendre à un gros changement de
stratégie dans la lutte contre le virus
chrome est que en cours des 100 premiers
jours en poste il le changera la
situation il parle de l'obligation de
porter leur masque il dit que ce sera le
gouvernement fédéral qui gérera la
situation mais il ya quelques instants
il nous a assuré que le pire est à venir
il y aura plus de décès plus de
souffrance la situation ne va pas
s'améliorer immédiatement beaucoup de
difficultés reste à venir
vous dites ça sera pire plus tard c'est
ce que dit en tout cas prévient joe
biden la campagne de vaccination est ce
qu'on y met un énorme espoir aux états
unis comment se passe justement cette
campagne la stratégie de campagne de
vaccination sur place mais on commence à
vacciner les professionnels de la santé
ils ont la priorité ce sont les
premières personnes à être vaccinés et
seules quelques personnes des élections
des réactions allergiques donc il semble
que la situation à 11 bien puis ensuite
ce sera au tour des personnes âgées des
personnes particulièrement vulnérables
des personnes dans certains domaines qui
ont ou auront la priorité
donc on a vraiment choisi certaines
personnes afin que la sécurité publique
soit garanti au mieux on parle de jours
en france
du coup de la santé très cher aux
etats-unis est-ce que ce vaccin est il
gratuit pour les américains a promis que
le vaccin serait gratuit que personne ne
devrait payer pour le recevoir
effectivement pour le moment il est
distribué gratuitement puis milliards de
dollars ont envie de côté par
l'administration tracteur pour l'ade la
dispense du vaccin
on est certains se demandent combien de
temps cela va durer et si ce fonds dont
elle disparaît est ce que les américains
sans assurances devront payer les
américains pour le moment ne payent rien
mais on ne sait pas combien de temps
cela va durer
nous avons des systèmes d'assurance
privé aux etats-unis est certainement
les assurances font prendre en charge ce
coup mais ceux qui n'ont pas d'assurance
pourraient un jour de voir à payer merci
caleb maupin d'avoir été avec nous le
rappelle vous êtes correspondant rt aux
états unis merci d'avoir été avec nous
pour vu de l'extérieur